elle vient d'ouvrir son nouveau magasin
de 1200 m² à coignières la start up all
tricks a enregistré une croissance de
30% en 2021 avec six boutiques en france
elle réalise plus de la majorité de son
chiffre d'affaires en ligne 2021 une
année durant laquelle elle a orienté sa
stratégie vers l'économie circulaire du
vélo on a la chance d'être sur des
produits qui sont durables par
définition à vannes oc s'est entretenu
ça peut durer longtemps on s'est quand
même un peu dommage en une proposition
de valeur auprès de nos utilisateurs de
leur dire historiquement vous vend que
du neuf on sait faire que ça alors qu'on
est capable de créer la boucle
l'engagement dans l'économie circulaire
de sept entreprises du e-commerce est
passé par le rachat du site troc vélo en
février 2021 une plateforme de vente de
produits cycliste entre particuliers
c'est aussi le lancement du programme
seconde life là on vient racheter des
produits à des particuliers ou à des
professionnels sur un vélo notamment que
ça peut être d'autres produits qui
nécessitent une intervention technique
le changement d'une batterie le
changement des pneus le changement de la
chaîne et des cassettes avant de pouvoir
être revendus là pour le coup
directement par nos soins pour engager
une nouvelle vie d'après les premiers
chiffres d'ahold tricks la plateforme
troc vélo rend possible plus de 50
millions d'euros de transactions par an